[Musique]
Hollywood et vérité
si quelqu'un ranger du risque la série
de toute une génération qui a transformé
deux écureuils inconnus en superstar
international
mais tandis que le succès propulsatifs
que tout pourrait s'effondrer
[Musique]
détruit par la vanité
tout le monde
dévoré par la tentation mon amour du
fromage m'a perdu je ne peux m'en sortir
et une possible que le destin réunissent
de légende vivante
[Applaudissements]
je pense à un reboot personne veut d'un
reboot
et 3 déguisements attrape le premier
truc que tu trouveras sérieux
[Musique]
cet endroit est bizarre tu te rappelles
ce style d'animation ou tout avait l'air
réel mais où rien n'était réaliste
[Musique]
c'est évident non parce qu'on dirait que
vous parlez à cette fenêtre non on
dirait que c'est vous que je regarde ok
regardez mes yeux qui regardent droit
dans vos yeux
[Musique]